elige el número correcto en cada valor
de posición para hacer
6000 794.500 62 milésimas y lo queremos
aquí es colocarnos en cada valor
posicional para entender qué es lo que
está representando cada número y así
seleccionarlo en estas columnas tenemos
en los millares 6 este 6 nos representa
6 por mil 6000
entonces nos vamos a la columna de los
millares y tenemos seis millares 1 2 3 4
5 6 en las centenas tenemos 7% 700 este
7 nos representa 7 centenas 1234567
centenas este 9 nos representan 9
decenas 90 así es que tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 9 decenas y en las unidades
tenemos un 44 nos representa 4 unidades
1 2 3 4 y nos vamos ahora con las
décimas tenemos 5 en el valor posicional
de las décimas lo que nos implica 5
décimas 1 2 3 4 5 el 2 centésimos ahora
que es el valor que está junto tenemos 6
este 6 nos representa 6 centésimas así
es que contamos 123456 centésimos y
finalmente en las milésimas tenemos 22
milésimas
2 y comprobamos nuestra respuesta
es correcta